all right this is the pajama war
contrary to what the title card looks
like it has nothing to do with tree
trunk so it made you very happy yes but
she probably had the best joke and the
whole thing just comes out mazing they
treat shows get your hot buns up there
and mr. big just like it gets really
angry doesn't even say a line just runs
up slap to me it's just like what'd I
just say get her hot butt slats again
wait you slapping me slaps him they
leave the food and they just quietly
walk away like that was it I'll say
myself I hope that's it I hope they
don't come back and they don't and that
was so funny and then left a bunch
outside - yeah well they left I'm like
what we'll leave the food with you but
that's it BB didn't even bring the food
ok they're doing this lumber party start
following up on what we were saying in
the last one and whether or not they can
sir keep an interesting character going
with her they play I think with musical
chairs so I think they called you like
something different yeah and they if you
don't sit down apparently you're put in
the closet to think heavenly thoughts 7
min heaven yeah 7 minutes in heaven
and they go in she has a secret way out
he's like I just haven't hung out for a
while let's just hang for a bit and they
go do that go through sort of secret
compartments of the of the castle and
the candy people panic big shock
probably the best line in the whole
thing well what do you say maybe they'll
surprise me and not do something crazy
or something yeah those good so so they
just suddenly you know it turns into
Loretha flies when they're all deciding
who's going to be the new princess and
most the guys take in so call themselves
princess and they're about to throw each
other like in this giant pit but then
they come back in time it's like what's
going on come on I'll read your story
they just all get their sleeping bags
and listen to the story and it just
looks over pictures that
of them just hanging out that's it you
don't know if that's like opening up
feelings again or it's just like I know
those was a good time um and she
addresses that she's trying to be more
laid-back and she's not trying to be a
spy heavy I'm paranoid as before but
again you kind of see clearly why she
has it just insane again very much like
politics
um I actually very much believe it's
like people I go why do they put on this
fake facade and not tell us everything
because people would act fucking insane
if you knew everything that was going on
people love to act insane over shit and
as much as people say tell me the truth
no one wants to know they really don't
you really don't and that's why it's
like I'm not as shocked that we're being
watched or anything that's just so like
ignorance is bliss I mean I like to know
some things don't get me wrong but I'm
just gonna make the assumption I'm not
gonna know everything in the world I'm
damn happy being a moron yeah me too so
yeah so this episode was I mean to me it
was okay again it felt a touch slow um
but but just enough interesting stuff
again they sort of keep that
believability with the characters when
she says yeah we just haven't hung out
for a while it it feels like something
just a friend would say to a friend like
let's just do that let's just leave this
place you know it just feels like real
people
hello I'm calling me up for this stuff
yeah it's just like dude we haven't come
on man next time we've done in a while
and watch Adventure Time so yeah I mean
it's one of those like there's
definitely fun stuff with the candy
people going nuts it's the funniest
thing is just watching Jay crazy it's
hilarious great the the candy feed
points I guess I never get too much into
their craziness it never made me laugh
too hard but it's okay away again
there's just something about like okay I
know they're gonna be nods I know just
the candy people in general never
interest me that much
I think they're to me what tree-trunks
is to you they're just a little too
stupid but I get it I mean it's like
it's sort of part of it that's just part
of the world and everything and sort of
part of creating her identity too so um
I thought it was okay I did think it was
great but I was okay
what do you think I thought it was fun
um and again I'm just a sucker for the
show but uh no that was fun with a yeah
scene the title card in tree trunks I
was like ah but no that was hilarious
this the whole scene I liked that it was
like this slow D evolution it wasn't
just instantaneous into mad chaos it was
like Oh first off it's like oh no we've
got to get them out of there or I wonder
what's going on are they okay quick
listen whoo oh they have a nice white
picket fence and a nice blah blah blah
he makes up some sort of weird a story
but it's funny because when they cut to
them that's what they are nanjing
there's gonna be other walking like you
know through nice bounces up after the
funny thing is when we cut to them like
wait wasn't it night and we're like you
know oh man they really let down their
game like something this slide it's like
oh it's like in virtual reality like I'm
almost wondering they did that just to
make people think like they made a
mistake I think so
but then I like just like you slowed the
evolution into these like you know Lord
of the Flies s with the breathing the
air under the door no no no suck it back
as it's in the Canon and just like it's
the whole chaos and then you have the
one uh I think it was crunch he's going
he's in the corner really looks like
they're building up something and it's
just like no he just rides the guy like
a horse or something like this I didn't
lead too much but it's like looking back
it's like that's that you really funny
could you think like something really
big yeah no he just takes it as well and
they're gonna throw them into the pan
like this big lot the crater whatever
and it's just like not just like let's
just read the story instead search each
everything you say you stay
I thought I was funny um I can
understand people getting kind of like
and all that stuff um I liked that yeah
it talks PV talks bit more about how she
needs to relax and pull back my like
whatever she plants she had that she
threw on Finn and then the little bird
things go all over him and I like that
you hear him talk about his dad you know
cuz that has been brought up in a while
and I mean I guess it's dumb as it
sounds I guess it's got to be weighing
on Finn's mind still you know wondering
about his dad and all that stuff and I
like that it was brought back up and
that they're showing that it is still
there and it's not just a solo it
happened and it's gone you know I think
the stuff with the two of them was so
oddly enough well written in that it
wasn't like it all came too well this is
all going to come to an arc by the end
of this episode
no they're just genuinely talking and
they're just they feel very real while
doing it that whenever come back to the
candy people I'm like a little bit more
like that you're really interesting and
yeah even waits talking about dad it's
not like a big emotional moment where
like he's gonna get teary-eyed or
whatever like the cat comes in he's
joking again it's like and that's kind
of how real conversations always go in
TV shows it's like okay you're building
this up again so we can have like my
masters here and then he was gone yeah
it makes me think okay mother go back to
that time and relive those moments yeah
every TV show it's exact line for line
to Tibet it's like you wouldn't bring up
something else kind of emotional like
that unless it would connect to the
story and again what I like is that with
Adventure Time because you can sort of
take all these different angles you can
have something that's like no no they're
just talking and you just want to feel
like these characters are real and I
think when you do that when you have
just little drops of that that don't
necessarily connect to a story but it's
in an episode where it doesn't have to
it works well and it makes them more
believable
you again it's I think when they become
more believable you want to be more with
them in episodes where big giant stuff
is happening yeah become concerned so
yeah no yes by no means a bad episode
I'm either that's it's fine it's funny
and everything um and yeah I think kind
of these past five or six that we see if
serve run like a nice little gamut of
like you know like serious episode funny
about they're mostly funny a but of like
kind of going back to the story
you know the continuing story but then
just showing a little bit of character
and having kind of throwaway nonsense
but it was kind of a good a good juggle
yeah and like I said every time we
talked about something like I want
everything gonna bring back one of the
other characters Flame Princess and
bubblegum come back what were that's guy
impact her character you know that we
show how it impacts her character like
it's everything we're thinking like they
address in the next episode which is
really cool I like I like to say that
goes back to your theory of them
watching us maybe even though they would
have to personal see this yes
prismo and the fly spy exactly
yeah